puisque à l'âge de 40 ans vous prenez
une décision et cette décision c'est de
changer de sexe justement je voulais
vous demander parce que dans le livre il
n'ya pas un moment vous expliquer de
façon claire en disant ce matin là je me
suis réveillé ça a été le déclic alors
justement je voulais vous demander quel
a été le déclic
si déclic il y a eu est ce que c'est un
très long et lent processus
je dirais plutôt un très long et lent
processus on ne choisit pas son genre
on est avec etc c'est un fardeau que
l'on porte toute sa vie jusqu'au moment
où on décide de franchir le pas que l'on
va chercher au plus profond de soi le
courage nécessaire pour affronter les
regards ce courage là vous dites à la
fois c'est ça demande un courage immense
et en même temps même si on sait ce vers
quoi ce que ce don ce qu'on va traverser
c'est une libération
plus tu as fait une grande libération
parce qu'on peut être enfin soi même et
non plus jouer un rôle non plus se
cacher derrière une peau qui n'est pas
la nôtre au départ puisque bon voilà la
nature nous a assigné un sexes à la
naissance mais ce n'est pas parce que
nous possédons ce sexe et la naissance
que nous sommes de ce sex je me suis
toujours sentie famille aujourd'hui
jeudi avec beaucoup de fierté
je n'ai jamais été un homme c'est ça
voilà c'est ça et pourtant et pourtant
pendant va jusqu'à vos quarante ans vous
luttez vous luttez vous luttez vous
donner l'apparence de c'est à dire que
vous vous mariez qu'est ce qui fait que
vous vous dites c'est à ce moment là
cette époque là je n'ai pas le choix il
faut que je fasse comme si ce n'est pas
quelque chose que l'on s'impose 16 à 2 2
voilà c'est bien de soi même en fait on
est éduqué dans la peau d'un garçon on
n'ose pas
surtout n'oubliez pas je suis né en 1970
que je me trompe pas celle menant à peu
près le même âge c'est simple une fois
la nsr année mais mais mais je veux dire
bon c'est une autre configuration que
qu'actuel actuelle une notation une
autre société
et aussi on se dit pas tout de suite
mais voilà je suis d'un autre sexe on se
dit mais qu'est ce qui m'arrive qu'est
ce qui se passe et on s'interroge
surtout à l'enfance l'adolescence est
terrible et on essaie de faire bien ce
dont on a et ce dont pourquoi on a été
programmé en tant qu'homme et tout
compte fait ce n'est qu'un leurre à
l'heure que mon s'inflige il faut cocher
les cases enfin voilà que l'on inflige
aussi aux autres alors mes petits
camarades ont bien sûr lu votre livre
avec beaucoup d'attention et d'émotions
et damien avait une question à vous
poser
justement quels sont les signes
concrètement qui vous ont laissé penser
qu'une femme était piégé finalement dans
ce corps masculin 15 est ce qu'il ya des
choses précise justement qui vous ont
fait croire que et bien vous n'étiez pas
un homme vous étiez mais bel et bien une
femme tout à fait déjà très jeune
l'attirance au niveau vêtements
l'attirance au niveau des couleurs
pourquoi maman se maquille tel et moi je
ne peux pas en quoi se fait-elle belle
et moi je dois m'habiller avec dd com
jeudi dans l'île des oripeaux 1 et même
plus tard je vais dire un aussi le le
regard le regard des autres cantons
d'abord c'est les premiers amis que l'on
a on se sent tout de suite différente
des amis on ne poursuit pas les mêmes
les mêmes les mêmes kate on n'a pas les
mêmes goûts ont subi parfois aussi les
remarques de la gente masculine
concernant l'argent de féminines sont
rien démontrer mon on les subit comme si
elles nous étaient adressées
ce sont un tas de facteurs qui montre
que je n'étais pas à ma place
vous vous dites dans votre livre
d'ailleurs qu'à l'adolescence au moment
du lycée notamment vous aviez de la
jalousie pour vos camarades féminines
envie d'être elle oui je n'ai je n'ai
dans ma peau d'homme je n'ai jamais
regardé une femme comme un homme quand
je regardais une femme je regardais ce
commentaire était maquillée ont encore
aujourd'hui comment elle était habillée
ses cheveux sur sa coiffure voilà donc
ce son retour autant d'indicés qui
montrent qu' on est plus proche de ce
que la personne d'observer et que ce que
l'on est soi-même
c'était pas une altérité c'était
quelqu'un qui était une de vos
semblables tout à fait emilie a
également une question alors valérie
d'asie vous avez été mariée oui vous
avez une fille oui comment elle a réagi
quand vous lui avez parlé de votre
changement de sexe bas
pas bien du tout forcément vous savez
quand quand on a une fille qui était
très proche ne sont pas pas en quelque
sorte je ne vais pas m'éterniser sur ma
fille parce que je voudrais garder un
petit peu de l'anonyamat pour elle mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est ma
fille a perdu son père elle doit faire
un deuil d'un être qui est toujours là
mais qui est différent d'apparence qu'il
n'a pas changé mais qu'il n'est plus qui
est à la fois les mêmes et un autre plus
tôt et est d'ailleurs dans le livre vous
dites je ne lui en veux pas je comprends
que pour l'instant ce soit fût il est
pour elle mais c'est normal
vous savez mon changement marié
attributions ma transition de genre
bon aujourd'hui mais j'ai terminé avec
les opérations la transition est fait
mon passing est formidable je n'ai sous
serre dodoz aucun rejet etc
mais je dis dans mon livre et je le
pense la transition est terminée la
sienne ne fait que commencer
comment ça va se passer quand elle va
rencontrer quelqu'un qui va lui demander
ton papa ou est il que devient-il je ne
voudrais pas être à sa place et ça j'en
suis fortement déçu vous êtes d'une
grande aussi compréhension elle voit
pour votre entourage parce que
effectivement on peut imaginer que quand
quand on vit quelque chose de si fort et
d'aussi important de bouleversant on
peut être tenté de penser d'abord à soi
tout à fait et vous vous pensez non
seulement à vous bien évidemment mais à
tous ceux qui entre guillemets vont
subir bas comme les dominos le
changement de sexe tout à fait jeu en
tant que président d'une association en
belgique et se nomme petite pub comment
vous allez arriver dans la nuit
on m'a traité un jour de transformer
semblables certaines de mes sens la
montre et et transphobes c'est
absolument faux pourquoi parce qu'un
jour j'ai osé écrire ce que d'autres
pensent peut-être tout bas et j'ai
peut-être tritre la défense des
personnes si ce genre et de la société
petit rappel une personne si j'en avais
une personne n'est dans son sexe et
quittant sont les gens râlent avec ça
et j'ai dit avant que les personnes
transgenres ne condamne la société de
transphobie font peut-être d'abord
regarder dans son assiette avant de
regard dans celle du voisin et voir ce
qui a conduit l'autre à me condamner
pour notre décision de vie c'est superbe
témoigne carolina a également lu votre
livre et voudrais vous poser une
question
les personnes transsexuelles sont
souvent victimes d'agressions ou en tout
cas de discrimination dans leur vie
quotidienne ça peut être au travail ça
peut être voilà dans la société en
général
est ce que vous vous vous ressentez
cette agression c'est une discrimination
parfois ce rejet de la spéciale on
rappelle que vous êtes professeur mais
je suis enseignante au niveau lycée en
france en belgique c'est le secondaire
supérieur dans le qualifiant de
techniques professionnelles j'ai plus de
200 250 étudiants déjà faire les
premiers pas sur mon lieu de travail ça
a été quelque chose de poignant parce
que je me dis voilà je vais franchir la
porte d'entrée d'un établissement que je
connais depuis de nombreuses années mais
c'est comme si j'allais le redécouvrir
dans une toute nouvelle peau et je n'ai
pas eu droit si des jugements et on a lu
forcément des interrogations il y en a
eu et heureusement il ya eu un tas de
questionnement et c'est en répondant aux
questions en présentant les choses
simplement en expliquant les choses
simplement qu'on se fait accepter
je me suis peut-être imposer à ma
famille immédiate et vos sens le plus
large dans ma décision mais je ne
voulais pas non plus me sentir imposante
dans dans ma profession et au sein de
mes amis j'ai dû expliquer pourquoi je
transiter et je vais dire que nous avons
ça je le souligne malgré tout une
jeunesse actuelle qui est formidable
elle c'est une enseignante qui vous et
vos élèves ont suivi et vous ont connu
dans l'autre sexe et vous connaissent
aujourd'hui pour celle que vous êtes
c'est à dire que la risque tout à fait
et même les nouveaux étudiants que que
je côtoie aujourd'hui ne m'ont pas connu
avant mais le téléphone sans fil est
rentrée scolaire il est clair que quand
les arrive dans ma classe ils me
connaissent ou davantage et moi pas du
tout donc je fais connaissance mais me
connaissent déjà et ce n'est pas ce qui
les intéresse chez moi et je vais même
vous dire où petite anecdote que j'ai eu
j'étais un garçon avons choisi une femme
aujourd'hui ils s'en moquent ils veulent
à mon professeur même elle même ce qui
les impressionne c'est plutôt ma
carrière de karatékas où les a apprécié
en gagnant là des moto2 vous encore
matin calme
voilà voilà voilà pas mal loti merci